bella tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a questo
video sono fa vj egiziano su di amazing
frog fra la rana fantastica proprio una
rana pieno di superpoteri in grado di
salvare il mondo dalla distruzione è
poco mi spiega perchè sono cosa state
guardando devo saltare per parti ah ok
ma chi è che sono stanche ragazzi è una
rana paranormale strada non sia l'area
cani in attimo bellissima auto
complimenti per aver mangiato fagioli
complimenti cazzo di santi sto facendo
regata era la banda si vent'anni di
lavoro passati a studiare per diventare
programmatore di videogiochi per fare
questo devi strisciare fino ai comandi
perché se non riesco a capire come ci si
muove a fatica tmnews io posso prendere
il nobel li voglio e va bene sono morte
tutte
posso pre no no ecco professano tornato
sul divano e la roba posso ok use of war
crimes c'è qua dentro
appena sono niente perché sono svenuto
non lo sapremo mai
allora ok sono entrato è una cosa
permesso per me ha proposto cucinare run
è perfetto è una roba
sì sì mi piace sosta camper bello si può
uscire per favore no io sono costretto a
morire qua dentro luca ragazzi la
genialata visto il gioco secondo me
rimane soltanto questa a sono uscito
proprio ok amazing frog jump to join che
adesso sono fuori sono fuori il
fantastico e adesso posso fare i cazzi
miei fuori di qua posso anche eco
sbattere sulle cose fantastico gioco
meraviglioso ragazzi si può vedere un
attimo
[Musica]
[Applauso]
una roba strana si può guidare la
macchina si si io io guido così la roba
allucinante comunque si sposano niente
io sbattere la faccia contro le portiere
di continuano viene eccoci qua da eccoci
qua ci abbia fatto ha messo mezz'ora a
capire come guidare
io comunque una una rana ceduta non l'ho
mai vinceva da denaro in tutta la sua
bellezza fantastico comunque se
guardassi la strada sarebbe un po meglio
cos'è
minchia l'istant basta basta come come
non ho scoperto questo gioco prima come
mi sono cappottato però non me ne frega
nome né frog ascolta zio che c'è gli
addominali perché non attiri secco
perfetto è la cosa più strana che abbia
mai visto
[Musica]
eccola la nuova frontiera del movimento
ceco quando quando camminare troppo
mestre in permesso sto bussando la
guardate come guarda il manifesto
bellissima ragazzino non so come
superare sta minchia di stagionato prova
c'è un'idea un'idea di iniziare uno
sforzo in più uno sforzo in pieno quello
sforzo però io non c'ho parole io a
differenza mia cosa però è la madonna
che cos'erano trappolino uno shuttle
ragazzi spider man mi fa una pippa credo
e adesso c'è frog il supereroe oppure
non l'ho presa ok l'ho presa no sono non
vedo un cazzo di un po più su non potevi
mettere già prima era una merda figurati
adesso il fax come non detto guarda si
perfetto
ragazzi io sto gioco non lo capisco
abbiate pazienza non lo capisco faccio
fatica perché mi è partita la corona
porca [ __ ] perfetto regal che di credo
che abbiamo fatto qua perché hanno
capito chi è che comanda in questo posto
c'è l'importante è quello pro mimì cosa
cosa ci fa una run perché ho appena
investito una rana su una scala fermo lì
scarse l'unica persona che il contratto
da un'ora e mezza del fermo un attimo
io ti amo vabbè c'è questo è amore vero
mi dispiace che allora ricambi il mio
affetto un fantastico senti non è che
non c'è signora non ci allarghiamo è
accolta mi dispiace no niente non c'è
verso lo sa anche prenderlo l'eau cosa
poi
ma dove si fa lo stesso schifo ma vabbè
ma questa è vietato ai minori ragazzi
cos'è sto sci non ho mai io ok
il bello di fare le cose insieme
noto con piacere che ci sono altre orge
in giro se prima era imbattibile adesso
sono ancora pin bat ecco come non detto
tamigi è questa via dal mio culo via dal
mio conto niente un'orgia
a 5 adesso prima era 13 a 5 io voglio
sapere la sera prima di fare sto gioco
che cazzo hanno fumato i programmatori
cosa posso entrare come posso andare
così in barba fosse avrei fatto meglio a
guardare dove stava sparando vuoi sapere
che è stato fatto per l'anniversario
tesoro
chiudi gli occhi e brava così va avanti
avanti avanti avanti avanti ecco siamo
arrivati puoi aprire gli occhi
ti piace il mondizia che di prima
qualità ecco allora non ti piace di un
ok no non in pubblico teso non in
pubblico a casa facciamo di meglio se
tranquilla più caso morti cosa guardi mi
stai dicendo che siamo davanti a dei
cinema e stai guardando i vestiti ho
detto di no devi smetterla di guardare
qui che cazzo di vestiti le donne ei
negozi di vestiti non si possono
trattare saldi vieni qua tesoro via ecco
perfetto non guardare non guardate solo
trovato la corona ho ritrovato la corona
e mela me no no no questa è mia devo
saltare assolutamente dalla rampa tutta
la vita fermi un attimo
ok ciao ragazzi pronti 3 2 1 boruc e
cosa bella che ho appena fatto perché
c'è una palla mi ha esaltato la portiera
perfetta è stato un atterraggio modello
ragazzi mi sono sono orgoglioso di me
stesso e il parcheggio ancora meglio
perché ci sono degli a k mi prendete per
il culo io posso sparare con gesù salto
adoro questo [ __ ] gioco pura ed è che
io ragazzi dovete capire che ce l'ho con
le casse perché sono stufi del trono
james bond usa va al rampino io non uso
al rampino ma uso la mia arma che mi fa
ecco come entrare di nascosto nei
balconi fantastico questa serie è molto
più comoda di quanto pensassi tra
l'altro fantastico sesta stanza per gli
sono svenuto da datemi un calo di
zuccheri qualcuno mi spiegherebbe il
senso di questo poster per cortesia dai
cazzo è come fuggire da una missione
segreta senza che nessuno se ne accorga
lo stai facendo giusto tesoro sei tu per
carico se stai facendo
non sei il mio hai visto mia moglie per
caso lavoro lui sto per mi piacciono al
come un [ __ ] continuo pure corto
wiser non come ti sei permesso di
toccarmi uno stronzo di me ecco perché
sono morto io con la moglie e mamma o
riba stanza adesso è morto ragazzi tifo
tipo max payne bellissimo ragala borse
sono fatto credo di non aver mai giocato
a nulla di più bello di questo mai l'oro
già eccoci qui [ __ ] che non sei altro
perché te la fai con un altro lo sto
tipo tardi mi tradisci mi tradisci lo
ridanno ora ganora che a noi ragazzi non
avete capito siccome mi mancava happy
meals adesso ci siamo
non sentite l'adrenalina che monta a
mille siete pronti per nostante più
epico della storia eccoci se
l'adrenalina che mi sale fantastico io
non potevo farcela con quella ma con
questa con questo se con quel ce n'è
un'altra sarebbe stato bello prenderla
però mi sa che non ci sono arrivato dato
sono caduto in piedi come fosse in archi
gta mi succedono ste cose
state scherzando posso segnare con la
macchina c'è col pazzesco ha vinto i
mondiali scarti del parcheggio mi
ascolti leva un passaggio eco bra entra
in macchina entra in marche dai che ti
porto in giro del portiere si aprono che
quella cosa lì dove sbattuto la testa e
una portiera si apre e tu ci entri
manco per il calcio è troppo figo
ragazzi ok va bene
certo basta mi sono basta la roba
allucinante gazzi bari sono saturo di
questa roba è una roba tv7 strunfi con
applique testing ragazzi voglio vedere
ok diciamo lega queste cose le provo nel
prossimo perché non ce la faccio a
reggio nel mio cervello chiede pietà la
batte quasi gozzi muletto tanto c'è
un'altra mappa addirittura da giocare
fantastico la prossima volta ragazzi
faccio qualsiasi cosa era solo per
provare diciamo stupito di premi
quindi ragazzi io io e la rana wags mag
se io non fossi episodi ragazzi cosa sei
tu sei video è piaciuto lasciato
commento mi piace anche a pagani
facebook e come noi vi dotate la
descrizione 6 condividete com'è che
questi costano dei figli della madonna
iscrivetevi ci vediamo il prossimo video
e le ragazze